thank you very much for coming to this
talk been introduced I'm a research
engineer on econ art project which is a
num focused sponsored open- Source
computational macroeconomic tool kit and
I will be talking a bit about what's
going on with open source software and
economics especially
macroeconomics uh and recent advances in
using deep learning to help with these
kinds of tools and uh then briefly talk
about where we think things are going in
the near future so uh the story of
computational macroeconomics and open
source might start in the
mid90s uh with a software tool called
diner developed by Mel juliard at the
bank of France in 19 94 and this is at a
time when in macroeconomics what's
what's really big are Dynamic stochastic
General equilibrium models which make a
lot of very strong assumptions in order
to be trackable over time so this
involves representative agent modeling
which means you take an entire sector of
an economy and collapse it into one
agent that's sort of optimizing its
problem and that part of the economy and
then you make assumptions about complete
markets uh things are clearing in
certain way
um and this these uh these assumptions
make the the models tracable and uh it
really the main stay of macroeconomics
during this period and Diner uh Pro
provides it's still ongoing as a project
like a domain specific language for
defining these kinds of models so you
could very easily spin up a real
business cycle analysis uh model um and
it was originally written in C and they
rewrote the pre-processor in C++ and
they made these models that were
pre-processed portable to mat lab and Sy
and new octave and very recently they're
now porting this to Julia and um this
kind of proves that some kind of
computational macroeconomics is useful
to the world um but uh the great
financial crisis of 2008 really threw a
lot of these methods into doubt um this
Dynamics pass General equilibrium
representative agent paradigm could not
predict understand why there was a great
financial crisis because to explain that
crisis you need to be able to have
speculative asset bubbl uh heterogene
heterogeneity in agents so some people
get affected by the crisis more than
others you need Inc concrete markets and
so there's a lot of there become a lot
of pressure on the economics Community
to uh really take seriously different
kinds of more complex models and around
the same time there's a lot of new
software paradigms which I expect this
audience is handly familiar with so uh
faster versions of python that mean you
don't have to code things directly
C++ uh Julia GPU programming new open
source development workflows new
computational science presentation tools
and into that environment um a new wave
of Open Source tooling has uh emerged um
one of the notable projects is Quant Eon
which is another num Focus bu sponsored
project and um it really made ways
within economics because Thomas Sergeant
who the Nobel Prize winner is one of the
kind of leads on it so it's very
difficult economics a very slow moving
field it's hard to build legitimacy with
it but when a Nobel prizes Winer puts
our stamp on it it you know it's good to
go right so um so Thomas sergeant and
John steri and others have started to
look at juon it's I it's years old now
um and but really it's it's it's lecture
notes in computational notebooks and
then like a lightweight library of
building blocks that are used uh in the
curricula that sort of perform sort of
utility functions and you can go explore
it it's sort of the basic building
blocks for economics teaching um they
have it in both Python and Julia um but
this has gotten like a lot of people
excited within economics of using open
source
tools
um but the um in terms of like actual
modeling building more complex models um
the the trend now is towards
heterogeneous agent modeling so rather
than collapsing that entire sector into
one agent you start to say well actually
you know the economy realistically has a
wide you know range of different kinds
of for example consumer households and
they may may be affected uh by
unemployment differently they have a
different they have a distribution of
wealth rather than a SLE concentration
of wealth so this Cel Smith model is one
of the earliest henus agent Mac Rec
models to really take off and it's used
as sort of a like a like a test case for
a lot of these new methods but the
problem is that the more complex the
models are uh the the harder it is to
solve right you get computational
complexity with these higher dimensional
models and heterogeneous agents imply
that the you have agents that to
anticipate many other agents working in
the economy so they're high dimensional
almost by definition unless you do a lot
of tricks to make them more tra so just
to
um um make this a little bit more
Concrete in terms of some notation uh
I'm taking this notation from this
recent milar paper so we've got an
optimization problem an interal Choice
optimization problem there's an
exogenous State process it's a mark out
process driven by this Epsilon noise
that comes in at every period And
there's an endogenous State process s
that's being driven by both the
exogenous process and a choice X um
which is uh it has to satisfy some sort
of constraints like capital x like
constraints given the current state of
my choice so for example the um the
exogenous process might be uh in many
models my labor income my end in the
state is my bank balance my choice is
how much to consume today right and
um the problem is to maximize uh
expected discounted reward where the
expectation is over all future shocks
and given some current starting
place and um the the solution to this
problem is a decision rule that
uh you know when I see that I'm in a
particular state that includes the
exogenous and endogenous State um if I
make this decision I'm going to maximize
that discounted future lifetime
reward and um some other notation just
here if you have a parameterized
decision rule parametric decision rule
that's what you've got some bunch of
parameters Theta and um you want to
choose those parameters Theta that your
decision will best approximates the true
optimal
decision so that's the notation in
general and um the way people have been
doing things
um I want to say you know past 20 years
this is well at least I mean um dynamic
programming Solutions also are used in
this Dynamics stas equilibrium framework
they've been adapted to these
heterogeneous agent Solutions as well um
so this is just a development equation
it turns that lifetime reward problem
into this recursively defined function
and it can be solved using dynamic
programming um so you're searching over
a grid of State spaces very
systematically um reinforcement learning
uh techniques use the same kind of set
framing for some reason they aren't used
very much in economics per se Economist
love exact results um but you could use
that and then um if it if it's a finite
Horizon problem you could use backwards
induction which is essentially dynamic
programming only um you have a finite in
state so you just iterate backwards so
um but the so and then this is a one of
the many dynamic programming algorithms
the simplest maybe the worst but also
the easiest to
present and um essentially you for each
state in the state space you um
you update your value function each step
in the loop with the currently
observed reward and uh discounted
expected future uh utility based on the
current state of the value function you
keep iterating that until it converges
and you get to uh provably under a
number of conditions that I will um
elaborate on you get to the the True
Value function from which you can get
the polic function read it off and
there's yeah sure
question okay so this is um this is yeah
that so um this is try to converge on
the value function and on each
step um you update the value function um
for each state so you look at every
state and you here we're assuming a
finite number of states and then for
that state you say I'm going to I'm
going to take my earlier value function
and plug it in here and then I do need
to maximize I need to
optimize this value for all available
choices given that state right and then
um you take that value and use that to
update your value function for that
state and then you continue um
a problem with this um so so there's a
couple expensive parts of this that
optimization stuff can be expensive uh
there are tricks to make it less
expensive um but the thing that actually
uh winds up killing this method is that
um in most economic problems you're
dealing with A continuous uh State space
you know like money is real value right
so um you have to discretize those uh
continuous spaces this method because
you need to iterate over a finite number
of things and then you have to do
interpolation over the values that you
found on those grid points and that
interpolation step point would be quite
costly um but also if you have a high
dimensional space and you're discoring
every Dimension you wind up with an
exponentially large problem and so uh
this is one of the ways that person
dimensionality shows up in the sort of B
equation
base problem
um okay but uh nevertheless these
methods are uh have been until recently
kind of the best the best thing
available and there's been a number of
uh software tools that use those and try
to make it make modeling this way easier
uh one of the nicest is Doo and doo
provides um in a rather interesting way
that's reminiscent of din a kind of
yamel based configuration file for
describing models which then get parsed
and can compile there's a python and
julier compiler for these um the python
compiler is very highly optimized for
GPU and Duma bunch of other things um
and um and it's uh there's a lot going
for it um you can express a wide range
of models there's many solution
algorithms implemented including um the
dynamic programming solutions that I
talked about before also projection
methods that um I won't explain because
I don't understand them and and then and
then given um a solution that can
simulate forward uh the markof chain
that the model implies using your
transition Matrix method and um it's a
very impressive piece of work uh it does
have some limitations it doesn't do um
time varying problems so if you limit
things to a like a Time invariant
infinite Horizon problem then you wind
up with essentially like an erotic uh
solution to the problem that's a markof
chain and that's easy to analyze but if
you want to have more complex things
like a life cycle problem where people
at different ages have say different
income streams and different
probabilities of debt and then you want
to overlapping Generations so you would
sign the equilibrium under those
conditions Doo won't do that um
D also doesn't have um things which help
you do Market aggregation so um if you
have agents sort of consuming and
laboring over time but they want to pool
their Capital into a resource that then
generates productivity in the economy
and that economy that distributes the
wages out to the agents which is what
happens one these typical models uh
there's no support for that we
don't at the moment there's some
experimental options but they haven't
been integrated um Park uh which full
disclosure I work on um is uh has some
similar scope it's python only um a lot
of it is about supporting this
endogenous grid points method which is a
trick to basically make that
optimization step in the dynamic
programming algorithm constant time um
and it has somewhat wider range of
models including those um life cycle
problems that I was talking about um it
uses Monte Carlo simulation for the
results of a model and it does have this
sort of population Dynamics you can have
agents that that die and then get reborn
and possibly pass on wealth to other
Generations or spread it around which is
something you would want to model if
you're trying to model macroeconomy and
it does do um some of this Market
aggregation um for example is used in
the Cel Smith so uh so there are some
downsides to hard which is a it relies a
lot on the hard coding of certain model
features and um we're working on
refactoring some of the things that be
more modular there a lot of work going
on part after a moment but it's another
one of the tools in this space um but
what's really shaking things up in this
field now are deep learning methods uh
as applied to macroon and so most of the
rest of this talk is going to be about
rather recent work uh describing how to
leverage deep learning to basically
defeat some of this cursive
dimensionality that we're talking
about um and there's this m m not paper
um which I'll be drawing on a lot
there's another similar paper uh
byov and Shyer um Shen Sher and Sh cre
paper that are about estimation that all
also touch
on so um the for deep learning for
heterogeneous age macro uh this is the m
m technique but the over overall
strategy is basically to um use the uh
objective function of the of the neural
network that you're training to encode
all the model equations um that are
important so uh unlike in a kind of deep
learning classification task where
you're looking at say mean squ mean squ
error between um some something you're
trying to predict and the results of the
model BAS on some training data set here
uh what you're what you're doing is
you're defining the optimization problem
and you're just using the neural network
as a generic uh sort of function finder
you it's finding the function that
optimizes that equation right so the
question is how do you turn all the
relative model equations into a function
such that um minimizing it solves for
everything including the optimal policy
of the agents and and uh the trick that
uh m m will not use um is they they have
to combine all the model equations into
one operator that includes not just all
future shocks but the randomized initial
State and this is uh again if this is in
a time invariant setting so um it you
know there's just a probability
distribution of where you start and then
there's probability distribution of
where you go and while it's iterating
over time there's neotic distribution
that's stable
so
um they've got a whole you know I'm
going to skip ahead to the example um
just to make it a little bit clear right
so um one of the sort of simplest ways
to do this is you this is a problem this
is a consumption saving problem um
somebody this is a person um they have a
wealth and they consume out of that
wealth um anything they have left over
after they consume they gets affected by
an interest rate uh they they earn uh
income every period their income is a
random number that's a log normal
distribution right and um one way you
could do this is you could just encode
that lifetime reward function directly
into the optimization function of the
neural um and it turns out that works
okay um there's uh clever ways to do it
where you use the bment equation or use
a first order condition of the iation
problem you can compare those results
and you can compare different neural
network architectures but this one works
fine for presentation and works
surprisingly
little if you use their algorithm and so
this is the algorithm they use um and
it's quite interesting so um remember
that when it was talking about dynamic
programming we're saying that that
relied on a grid over all the states
right and that led to this Cur of
dimensionality because the grid is you
know exponential number dential right
but instead of using a grid here um what
they're doing is they sample from the
model like at each at each step of the
of the algorithm they have a model and
you can sample from the model using
Monte Carlo sampling and then um when
they compute the empirical loss to
retrain the neural network rather than
training a an entire grid they just
train it on top of that symbol and that
symbol can be any size uh but it is
probabilistically reflecting um over
time it converges on this erotic
distribution of the simulation which is
much more compact than the uh the entire
GD space just to do an intuition because
so if I've got like a 1D so I want to
compare um like a unit cube and a unit
sphere right and I've got like a
1D uh unit
cube and 1D unit sphere they've got the
same volume right if I've got 2D units
now I've got this
Square about this circle right and the
circle is smaller than the
square
3D
um
now I think actually the if you look at
the compar comparison the volume of
the sphere in the circle it actually
goes up a little bit but then it starts
dropping down M you get higher and
higher dimensions of the sphere it's a
smaller volume relative to the uh the
cube hyper Cube so um
that's and if we're sampling from a
probability distribution the probability
dist distribution has to have unit mass
of of one total right so most of the
parameter is never going to be
reached um especially if there's things
in the model that are driving into
convergence so this is um this makes a
lot of things uh doable that were not
doable before this is the whole
algorithm um I think I'll just go
through it again just uh is want to
repeat myself and find out something
complicated all right so um you have to
construct this uh this risk function
this objective function and that is
basically describing optimization
problem and constraints um you have some
sort of sample you have starting sample
from the model and you define the
empirical risk on that sample um you
have some neural network which is this
parameterized uh decision rule right
and then you fix the initial Vector
coefficients so you initialize the
neural network and you start training
the machine and you to you start finding
this uh Theta that optimizes or
minimizes imperal Risk by simulating a
lot of data and then um you get the
gradient of the uh the cost of running
the model on that data and then you
update those coefficients and that's
just you know back on a neural network
right and then um if you converged you
stop right and if uh and then you look
at whether it's um it's good enough and
if it's not good enough uh then maybe
you have to change your architecture you
know maybe your like activation
functions are not the right prop set and
that's kind of where the fields bit uh
sort of moving um so we already talked
about that problem
okay um how much time 10 minutes 10
minutes I'm just going to keep going do
questions
the so um estimation is is like a
different different sort of problem uh
entirely so um so say you have a model
you've got these equations you've set up
what the agents are supposed to be doing
what their incentives are right um and
then you can solve the model and you get
the optimal decision rle uh but maybe uh
this happens a lot there's a bunch of
like free parameters in the model that
you know stand for things that have that
are like empirical right you know you
might have mortality rates be a
parameter of the model you might have uh
income streams uh be a parameter of a
model you could get from say the IRS
right sort of General income streams you
could have um all all the sorts of
things that you would actually want to
track and use data to calibrate are
going to be these
parameters and um one question you might
have is assuming this model but not
assuming the parameters of the model um
and knowing that there's certain um
things that I want to Target with the
model like interest rates right
um what parameters I do I need to make
the model predict those interest rates
so this is kind of a ual estimation of
abductive inference kind of task and
um so uh assuming let's see where was
I okay so you have the model you're able
to solve it but you want to know um the
sorry this is supposed to
be the notation little bit wared um
point is if you want to do that
optimization um you have to run the
model many times and you might have to
solve it many times and both of those
going to be expensive and so what uh
shind shim and shidaker have done in a
paper is they there's a trick which is
you can do um deep sort in mod so uh
this is also happening in in some other
fields where you've got really complex
agent based models um surrogate models
are cool that's when you have a
complicated model to hard to run and you
essentially train a neural network to
know the function that the model
implies um and then you use that for
your analysis so
um what you can do is you take your
model and you can ah right and and if
you're want if you're trying to estimate
parameters right these these things that
you don't know about your model that you
want to somehow fit on onto some like
empirical results um the trick they use
is this pseudo State trick so remember
we're talking about having a model
you've got the state space and then you
you're seeing well what's the best thing
to do at each state right but if you
just include the parameterization as a
pseudo State um then you can just start
sampling from this now large State space
but um whereas before right we had this
dimensionality here we've got kind of
the opposite sort of economies of scale
right it's really cheap to sample from
this model you can do it in a really
parallel way and um you can get as much
data as you want okay um there's no
computational complexity to that right
um and then you can basically train a
giant G that work to get as close as
possible to like something that
interpolates all that data and uh one of
the reasons why this works pretty well
is double descent so double
descent is this uh rather recently
discovered property in neural networks
where um you've got this pattern of um
so this is sort of the size of the
neural network in terms of number of
parameters in each
layer um this is the training
error and this is the test
error and uh you know when I learned
about this stuff you know in school uh
what we were told is there's a bias
variance tradeoff right and if the
neural network is too simple then um you
try to train that neural network it's
never going to get all the complexity in
that data right um but then if you make
the noral network sort of so complicated
that it has no error then it's going to
overfit that data and it's going to be a
big problem so the kind of the the art
of it was find finding The Sweet Spot of
the right amount of model complexity
that's has the right inductive bias of
the problem you have so that you um
minimize the
tester and then uh with all this new GPU
stuff they realiz well if you just like
blow past this entirely you wind up
getting a double descent and you start
reducing your training error again and
you fully interpolate all the data you
had before and this winds up becoming uh
something like a coution process I think
this still unknown why this phenomenon
happens um but recall that you know oh
the thing you want you'd be scared of
right is if you have noisy data this is
completely capturing like baking in any
noise of that
data but recall that we're just sampling
from like a model that we've already
made so the surrogate model doesn't have
noise in it besides the kind of random
like the the intrinsic noise of the
exogenous stuff that your sample
so
um so they find this works really
well and then they find that um the nice
thing about having a a deep word uh
surrogate model is that all the
derivatives are just there in the model
and if you're doing an optimization
function you would probably want to know
say the derivatives of the of the
outputs with respect to some some inputs
of Interest such as these parameters and
so it's easier to do the
optimization so this is very encouraging
for the field oh one more thing right um
I'm not sure I'm going to explain this
properly but this is hopefully
tantalizing turns out if you put the
parameters as pseudo States into the
model when you solve it rather than
doing so it used to be that everyone
said well you have a way of solving the
model and then you have this extra step
which is to estimate the model and you
might have to solve the model you know
end times as you search the space
parameters that you're trying to
estimate then some people have said well
you could just include the parameters in
the state space when you solve the model
and then when you solve it as long as
you construct your objective function
correctly you get um both the decision
Rule and the estimation all in one
shot and so
um this is sort of clobbering clobbering
a lot of people's ideas of how things
are supposed to done and it's pretty fun
um so uh I suppose the the take
takeaways are that deep learning is
making a lot of things that were
infeasible uh more feasible in terms of
what you can do in macroeconomic
modeling um but where things are at
there's there's sort of some some
general libraries for earlier forms of
modeling and then there's ad hoc
academic code for new neural network
based methods and so for if I were to
predict the near future of where this is
going um and what the field kind of
needs it's like better stand
standardization around model
configurations and apis like we've had
with Diner like with Doo and park Etc
but building that out so it's a nice
reusable sort of Open Source set of
software tools and then there's a lot of
research needed on how to encode models
into neural networks and I've only just
touched on that there but you know
hopefully you can understand why there's
both complexity and
[Applause]
potential